we're following a dangerous new ecoli
outbreak linked to Salinas California
place known as the salad bowl of the
world the CDC is warning consumers not
to eat fresh express sunflower Crisp
chopped salad kits that's what they're
called at least eight people in three
states have become ill it's not clear if
these cases are linked to a recent more
widespread outbreak from contaminated
romaine lettuce that sickened 102 people
in 23 states but it might be Jonathan
Vigliotti is in Salinas so Jonathan good
morning what do we know about the source
of this new outbreak that's what
everyone wants to know yeah and good
morning to you Tony and the CDC at this
point taking no chances calling on all
Americans to avoid romaine lettuce that
was grown here in Salinas Valley listen
grocery stores began removing the
lettuce last month but the concern
remains if it's still in people's
refrigerators we'll tell you how you can
check in just a second but first to why
it's making people so sick to begin with
romaine lettuce from Salinas California
is once again being investigated as a
possible source of an e.coli outbreak
eight people have fallen ill one of them
suffering kidney failure the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention is still
investigating what exactly in fresh
express sunflower crisp chopped salad
kits is the source of the e.coli but it
does contain romaine lettuce which was
contaminated with e-coli in a large
outbreak earlier this year caused by a
different strain health policy experts
say contaminated water containing animal
feces often carries the bacteria lettuce
is probably more vulnerable to
contamination in part because it's kind
of has a lot of nooks and crannies as an
industry we know we have to do more
Christopher Velez is president of a
trade group representing romaine growers
and shippers in Salinas he agrees with
the CDC to avoid the Fresh Express
product and clean areas where it was
stored as a consumer somebody who eats
lettuce from this region how concerned
are you when you hear not just one but
now a second ecoli outbreak I think for
us we have to look very critically at
the advisory and what we know
we'd advise anybody in the public to
follow that during peak season Salinas
Valley actually grows about 80 percent
of the nation's romaine lettuce the good
news is that season is now over if you
want to check where your produce is from
Gale you can simply look on the package
is usually listed right there on the
front alright now we know what to do
thank you very much Jonathan